Kelsea follows me on twitter you can
follow me there Dave Ramsey do you see
tiny houses as bad as buying an RV no
not mathematically on an RV we have a
long track record on an RV we all know I
mean you can it's not it's not rocket
science to figure out 100% of them go
down in value all lost and so if you buy
a $30,000 RV it's going to be worth you
know ten thousand dollars in twenty
minutes right we know that it's not to
say you shouldn't never buy an RV but
you just got to be able to lose that
money and not notice and so anytime
you're buying stuff with motors in it
you pretty much got that cars boats you
know motorcycles almost all of them go
down in value and some of them extremely
rapidly and the typical RV is very
rapidly goes down in value do neut do
tiny houses go down in value well we
don't know it's not being on the scene
long enough there's not a track record
like theirs with RVs you can look over
the last 20 years and see what our v's
have done it makes you puke you know but
in terms of the mathematics on it right
there's just no time it's just awful now
again I'm not saying I'm not mad at the
RV business and if you want to buy an RV
I'm not mad at you but you got to pay
cash and you got to be able to absorb
the loss in value within your net worth
and not notice it's a very large toy now
is a tiny house fall in the category no
I don't know that they'll go down in
value as a matter of fact I'm not
predicting that they'll go down in value
I'm just not predicting that they're
going to go up in value like a regular
house would and so I'm not suggesting
people buy tiny houses but for different
reasons that I don't suggest they buy an
RV you buy tiny house you're usually
buying that instead of staying in a
rental for a period of time and building
up a good downpayment in buying a home a
full-size home that has a track record
of going up in value now first thing we
got to observe about tiny houses is that
they are tiny
it's the definition right and
consequently the market for them is
going to be tiny the number of people
that are willing to live in a tiny house
versus a traditional home is much
smaller no pun intended so it's a tiny
market for tiny houses and anytime you
have a tiny market for something you're
going to have tiny rates of return and a
hard time selling stuff so I don't know
how hard your time you're going to
selling your tiny house and therefore
how much it's going to go up in value so
I'm not predicting that they are going
to be matter fact I'm predicting that
they are not going to be a huge
appreciation because the market for them
is going to be small no pun intended and
so when the income there's a small
demand you're going to have a small
increase in value you might even have a
decrease in value but I don't think it's
going to be thing like RVs so our tiny
house is as bad as buying an RV no but
is one point type of poison worse than
another kind of poison well one kills
you faster than the other one that's all
you know so I'm not suggesting either
one of them unless well I just wouldn't
suggest a tiny house period I might buy
an RV if you had the extra money to
throw down the toilet but a tiny house I
just think you're going to get
aggravated by the whole thing and it's
so fat oriented and it's it's got this
cool hipster thing to it and all this
and I think you're just going to wake up
and go yeah now I could be wrong it
could go up in value but I don't think
they will because I don't think there's
a number the number of people that are
going to be in the market to buy one
later is going to determine the increase
in value and it's got to be by
definition a smaller market just so many
puns here hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
Oh
[Music]